[Music]
we gotta talk about the collapse of
voyager digital this morning even after
ft access sam bankman freed came in and
bailed them out with an over 450 million
dollar loan
they're still filing for bankruptcy and
now individual investors in the platform
and retail investors can't get their
money out folks uh kevin o'leary i want
to start with you what's happening here
and then i want to hear from uh
wonderful and maybe how things are
different with you
you know this is nothing new um
in in
the story of leverage and so in every
cycle what happens is various actors
companies
take on more and more aggressive
positions using leverage to goose
returns which is age-old it works it
definitely works
now what you're going to find in this
situation is many crypto operators
particularly lending platforms have
never operated it with such volatility
before so they were in the slow growth
from bitcoin you know
almost a decade ago from eight hundred
dollars all the way to sixty thousand
and all along the way some of them
became really aggressive in using
leverage which is the traditional hedge
fund model
now
what happens
and this happens in equities it happens
in bonds it happens in real estate it
happens in crypto cryptos the johnny
come lately new asset class with a whole
lot of newbies in it
you're going to see a whole series of
these actors get crushed to zero over
the next few months um
in in the contagion of of leverage being
caught offside with the lack of
liquidity voyager is not that big a deal
it's it's kind of
irrelevant in terms of you know
this is a diversified shareholder base
it's it's not fdic insured in any way so
it's not putting any stress on the the
government systems in any way
all the shareholders should consider
themselves
educated no different than when you go
to las vegas put it all on black and
it's red you lose
that's exactly what's happened here but
the great news about this and why this
is so good for the market and how this
helps the crypto market is it educates
the business models that aren't going to
work so it's like taking a big spatula
from the sky and scraping all the crap
out of the market and it's going to
happen very very quickly so anything
that was built on you know a business
model that isn't is not going to work or
can't sustain volatility is going to be
gone and it's a good thing it's a
wonderful thing it's going to leave the
industry much stronger yes we must mourn
the investors that got wiped out to zero
but even they are better off in the
sense that they've been educated
so how do you know what's safe kevin
o'leary what do you look for in a
company to know because we we voyager
was a public company we could look at
their statements and their filings from
march 31st and we see well they had
money and the ceo in interviews told us
hey we only lend to qualified
institutions or we lend the bulk of our
money to large institutions one of them
ended up being three arrows capital
where they lended 33 cents out of every
dollar they lent to who got completely
wiped out so how do we protect ourselves
even with public financials you own
crypto without leverage and you
understand your counterparty risk don't
worry by the time all the litigation is
over from all these bankruptcies you'll
know everything about everybody lawyers
are really good at doing that and
there'll be tons of class action if not
just straight on litigation to go after
any assets they can get and that's that
is sort of you know when a fish dies in
the ocean it goes to the bottom and that
protein is reprocessed by slugs and i'm
not saying lawyers are slugs they have
more than single cell proteins but they
know how to get the last drop of any
value there and they're going to get it
it's going to take five to seven years
but all of this is good so in when i
hold crypto and i know it's very
volatile i have zero zero leverage in
any of my positions because i know
tomorrow morning i can wake up down 38
in any token any coin any project and
and really that's exactly what's
happened so
you know but if you put on leverage you
learn the very very important lesson you
go to
zero i want to ask you how are you
different at uh wonderful how are are
you not lending to hedge funds like
three arrows capital or if you are how
do you vet them differently what what's
different about you why are you not
going to be a blockfi or a voyager
and this ties back into the question you
just asked kevin which is how does he
decide what's safe to invest in and one
of the things that he has been talking
about for many years before i even got
involved with crypto was just about
compliance and regulation and obviously
coming from the the world that he does
and so that is the difference with
wonderful and uh bit by and coinberry
which are a couple of the brands that we
have under the under the wonderful
banner
all of our
platforms are regulated by securities
regulators in in canada and what that
means is when we
offer products we have to vet them with
the regulators and so
we have to go to the regulators with a
plan around
how we're going to actually implement
something like staking for example uh
you know be able to assess the different
risk profiles have you know a bunch of
processes and backstops in place before
we can actually bring that product to
market now when you look at a platform
uh you know not to single out voyager
but just as it's in the news
that is something that did have some um
you know some state licenses in the us
but really didn't have the oversight of
a regulator like the sec or the ontario
securities commission in canada and so
products that they're offering
like uh that that offer yield to
customers and that's what we're seeing
implode right now nobody no regulator
had been looking at that or had vetted
that to see what types of risks exist
for the business and for the customers
and so the regulation piece becomes
extremely important and i think this
uh this you know these events with with
voyager with celsius and and with
blockfi which are all happening around
the same time this this crypto liquidity
crisis that uh it you know going back to
what kevin said it's an education for
users and for shareholders it's also
part of the growth of the industry so we
will see
regulators focus on this particular
issue going forward
and uh and we can look back at the
evolution of crypto over the last 10
years there's been significant events
like this before i see this as sort of
the second wave of uh
crashes in crypto that lead to specific
types of regulation the first was
in 2016 2017 where you had
crypto exchanges that were
run by individuals who would
uh
basically have control over all customer
funds so this is not even talking about
you know lending or anything like that
they just you would deposit funds and
then it would you know go into the ceo's
pocket basically and so that led to a
bunch of these debacles with quadriga
and and you know other things that led
to ccaa and people losing tons of or not
you know uh insolvency and people losing
all their funds and what came out of
that was regulators now saying crypto
exchanges that are regulated need to
have a third-party custodian that holds
customer funds it can't be in the ceo's
pocket and so that it's obviously in
hindsight it makes a ton of sense but we
needed to have that
um those incidents happen and so this is
i think the second wave of that
yeah that's really interesting because
you do get companies that uh like
voyager digital put it up on a screen
here they have these disclaimers at the
bottom that say hey uh you know they
they're a fincen registered company they
file public disclosures because they're
a public company and so it's certainly
challenging at best and and at worst
just outright discouraging and confusing
for the retail consumer to know hey like
who's regulated the right way like which
license am i looking for and so i guess
the question now is what's safe in this
kind of environment and i'm going to
start kevin o'leary i want to hear your
take are stable coins safe right now or
do we need to be worried that if bitcoin
drops to 10k we're gonna see the gemini
token go under because of all this over
uh rehypothecation or worse usdc goes
under and then any company that's
offering staking risks some form of
stable coin meltdown what's your take on
that
well
let's talk about that specifically
because i think it's a great topic for
several reasons reason number one is
people think that crypto the entire
sector is going to get regulated all at
once that's not going to happen
the most likely scenario and this is a
personal opinion but one i've been
working on in washington along with
others
is that we would like to get policy on
just stable coins first because stable
coins represent a very powerful and
efficient payment system and we think we
can get bipartisan support between both
parties supporting the american dollar
as a default currency for a global
payment system it's not going to be the
chinese one it's not going to be swiss
franc it's not going to be the euro it's
not going to be the british pound and
the reason it would
fall and default to the us dollar would
be that that is the currency used to
denominate most commodities and so the
challenge you have right now and why
there's so much pressure to solve this
is it's very inefficient to transfer us
dollars over to geneva then put it into
swiss francs and then buy swiss nestle
stock or whatever it is you want to do
over there it's really slow very
inefficient very costly not transparent
and not easy to audit and so all of that
problem goes away with a stable coin now
the proposed policy that you'll find in
great in granular form in both the
hagerty and to me bills and i met with
both of them as as many others have this
is very simple policy what it looks as
it says okay for any stable coin any
stable coin an audit every 30 days and
any asset underlying holding up the
value of the coin or token
cannot have a duration of more than 12
months now you've seen that policy
before it's called a money market fund
and you'll find it at fidelity and
putnam and many other financial services
entities that are fdic insured circle if
it wish that issues usdc could become a
bank they could be fdic insured if they
wanted to but they are sort of leading
the pack with crypto in terms of payment
systems under a stable coin that has not
broken a buck so you can you've seen
even tether trades below a dollar it's
0.999 right now and so when you break a
buck you lose a lot of confidence so
what i'd like to see happen here is that
we regulate stable coins first because
of their utilitarian value within the
crypto universe and that get done in
this calendar year and the reason that
might happen is toomey is retiring and
he is a driving force as you know on the
hill and is really behind this momentum
and this bill and has lots of support
from both sides of the aisle so i think
that's good now obviously what happened
to luna is an example of what not to do
so again
a sad situation billions lost but a
great education to the market
algorithmic based stable coins nah i
don't think we're going to do that again
i'd rather see something back by us
dollar or assets that are very liquid
that can have duration less than 12
months so that makes sense to me so at
the end of the day the bad ideas get you
know removed by the big spatula and
again it's unfortunate for those
investors that didn't think it through
but not all stable coins are alike usdc
being the leader currently now having
said that
if you go look at current yields across
the spectrum of duration from one month
to 12 months it's only 50 basis points
right now so right now usdc while it
hasn't broken a dollar is not a great
place to park cash because you can do
1.2 percent
in commercial money market accounts in
u.s dollars so at any one time you have
to manage assets as you always have to i
think usdc when things stabilize and
there's more demand for it we'll
probably have rates 300 basis points
higher than one percent but you just
don't know and when you were putting out
loans on usdc platform it would have
been best to ladder them from one month
to 12 so you'd still be accruing three
to four percent but everybody's learning
that's my whole point that was a long
dissertation about what i think is going
to happen in stable coins but if you're
going to be in a stable coin it's only a
personal opinion usdc is the one that
has not broken a buck recently
yeah and so i want to ask a follow-up to
that and then go to ben the follow-up is
a lot of folks i don't believe realize
that when they do stake a usdc
stablecoin even though that coin is
backed by a dollar if it's then lent out
that person no longer has the right to
the claim of that dollar the person whom
the coin is lent to has that right and i
wonder is there a risk that uh companies
are leading a lot of retail consumers to
believe that oh no you can always rename
it for a dollar without mentioning that
oh but it's leveraged out 10 20 30 times
and ben i'm gonna end up asking you
after uh kevin o'leary here how many
times are these stable coins lent out do
we have any idea about that but kevin
o'leary for you isn't that a risk if you
take yield that you're actually becoming
a lender and if we have systemic shocks
or at least certainly going through a
bear market that you could even see a
usdc break a buck and even though it's
backed by the dollar
the people who lent out or staked lose
and the last person who's not staking it
up they get the dollar what's your take
on that so that's where you need
management and compliance and total
transparency and so those who have
opened accounts with circle itself
manage it under corporate accounts
understand exactly what you just
disclosed but also the company is
constantly monitoring its margin
requirements and exactly what it's got
and what it's holding and you can't if
you have an account with circle you're
getting a constant stream of information
answering exactly those types of
questions because they have their brand
to protect they also have that dollar
strike value to protect and they have
their corporate accounts and count
holders to protect and they want to do
that they want to emerge from this
successful even though it's been tested
with volatility and i will remind you
that recently it was disclosed that both
fidelity and blackrock each invested 200
million dollars in the series f
of circle that is a huge vote of
confidence in the middle of all of this
volatility we're talking about the
equity of the company and so they're the
most conservative money managers on
earth
putting a bet forward on circle becoming
at least one of the regulated
cryptocurrencies that are stable and so
at the end of the day you know they have
the risk too we all have risk but if i
have to bet i'll invest beside fidelity
and blackrock and that's exactly what i
did
ben your take on stable coins and what
do you all do at wonderful
how how was that sort of
you know when individual stake how do
you handle the disclosures for that but
also more interestingly can you give us
some insight into how often are these
stable coins circulated through the
system is it you know somebody deposits
a hundred thousand dollars and then that
gets cycled through five times is it a
hundred times how many times does that
lent stablecoin sort of move around
so so yeah a couple questions in there
and i think they're it's uh i i love the
you know the root of all your questions
comes back to there's a lot of retail
confusion about products and licenses
and what's regulated and what's not and
what the risks are that's what it comes
comes down to and
even for sophisticated people like you
pulled up voyager's website okay it's a
public company it's licensed by fincen
there should be some
comfort level with that and uh as much
as i you know i
compliance and regulation can be a
boring thing to talk about and i'm
actually a lawyer in a previous life you
know one of those uh bottom feeding fish
that kevin mentioned or whatever the
phrase was but um but you know as much
as i try to get away from that that's
really you know the dna of what we're
doing is really around regulation and
compliance and so much of that comes
back to disclosure and really helping
customers understand what the risks are
so just to kind of cycle through a few
of the topics and questions i think um
you know from for for users that because
this is just going to become more and
more
um important especially in light of some
of these incidents now so you know with
with fincen and fintrac
those registrations they're not actually
protecting the customer they're really
focused around anti-money laundering
rules and and um there's not
a customer protection that lies in there
it's really the licenses with the sec or
the osc the securities commissions that
have these mandates of protecting
investors and and users now uh in the
crypto space now that they've asserted
jurisdiction over that so those are the
regulators that are making sure that uh
customer funds are held by a third-party
custodian that if platforms like
wonderfi or bitbuy or coinberry are
doing staking that they vetted the
process as in the regulators have ended
the process and they're comfortable with
it and so
you know tying that back into what we do
we we actually don't offer staking
through our platforms yet but we are
we've been in discussions with the
regulators for for quite some time and
there's always pressures to bring new
products to market and obviously we you
know i i face that in my role and we
face that as a company but at the end of
the day in situations like this it's you
know it's better to be a bit slower
moving and make sure that the products
that you're offering are safe and secure
for customers because at the end of the
day this is no longer just an early
adopter crowd that we're dealing with in
crypto you're now really getting into
closer to some you know some mainstream
adoption so you're getting people that
don't have
uh necessarily the
sophistication or background of crypto
trading for years and so um there's a
lot of additional risks that come in for
those users so i think it just becomes
it becomes more and more important for
companies to be clear about what the
risks are with the platforms and i know
a big topic with some of the
with the liquidity crisis with some of
these companies we're seeing is that
there weren't really proper disclosures
around
what's being done with customer deposits
and that's crucial and so i think that i
mean that's
going to get weeded out with this and uh
and it's going to become something that
i hope retail users can um you know will
be able to to address easier and i think
it's great that you know you're talking
about this and bringing it you know to
the top of your agenda because at the
end of the day this is also
a place where people go to to learn
about crypto and how to access it and
what the risks are it's not just you
know not everybody goes and downloads
financial statements and reads them and
understands them i think people are
really looking to to voices
you know in in traditional finance and
crypto to learn and understand
so uh what risks would customers face if
they wanted to go to wonderful or would
they face any what kind of confidence
would they have that they're not going
to get voyager and we're not going to
see this sort of celsius limitation of
withdrawals and then maybe second if you
could speak to how how have signups been
lately are you noticing at the business
a little bit of a slowdown in the last
few months
yeah so definitely so
the second part first which is
generally i think the the whole crypto
industry all platforms have seen you
know a a general decline this year just
with with you know macro economic
conditions and and what's been happening
in the crypto market as a result
so i think you know generally there's
you know a bit of a softer market right
now but nothing that we haven't seen
before and in terms of confidence for
customers we we don't lend out any
customer assets
we've never done that you know nor will
we do that unless we find a way that is
you know is vetted and approved by
regulators that has you know doesn't
have the risk profile of some of these
incidences but you know it's not part of
the it's not part of the plan right now
i think our
our business really focuses around
providing a simple
compliant way for people to trade crypto
and just making it as dead simple as
possible and so i think some of the
strategies the high risk strategies that
you've seen with uh with some of the the
names in the news recently those are
people that you know companies that were
chasing you know higher revenue higher
returns and offering things that were
unsustainable for customers like 20
you know yields on their on their crypto
assets so that's something that
right now we we're not even allowed to
do that because we're regulated and we
would need to you know we need to get
through a process of the regulator to be
able to do that and now with in light of
these
incidents uh we
for us to get through a process with a
regulator to be able to offer a lending
yield product through bit by or through
coinberry
the regulators are gonna now have to get
comfortable with
all of uh you know all the risks that
we're seeing come out of uh of these uh
of these situations so it's gonna be a
you know it's gonna be a long process
before we would be able to do that
got it i wanna talk now broadly about
the crypto market kevin o'leary uh your
thoughts on how low can bitcoin go are
we are we going to 13k you know kathy
wood says uh 22 000 should have been the
200 week moving average floor and that
would have been tough to go through we
blew right through that we're going to
13. when do we go bullish here or do we
buy the dip or do we wait
it's impossible to know uh you know how
where the bottom is but i would say this
i don't believe we've seen the bottom
yet and i have a different view of it i
go back again to other asset classes
that i've invested in for decades in
every case
you know traditional bonds traditional
equities real estate alternative asset
classes
bottoms are reached with an event a
panic event as i call it and you can
find it in every asset class
you know back in the hedge fund days
when they started gating these large
multi-billion dollar hedge funds that
gated
shut down their liquidity caused panic
and you saw bottoms in equities as they
were being liquidated uh there's
long-term uh was one of the classics in
the last couple of decades
and it was it was a fund that was over
levered and blew up we haven't seen that
yet in crypto land there's no
no big guy has gone to zero yet and i
think that's still to come
hard to say who it is because it's going
to be because of leverage and
some kind of relationship
uh in a counterparty holding that they
have not disclosed and i'm just
speculating right now but that would be
very healthy for the market uh to have
that happen voyager is too small it
doesn't matter the rest of these guys
were kind of irrelevant in terms of
total market cap
bitcoin and the crypto market itself has
almost been cut in half in total market
cap
and and so you would think we're on our
way to the bottom but i like a big
big panic event that's always been a
great way to bottom it's towel throwing
it's capitulation it's massive volume
it's total panic in the streets and
always a great buying opportunity i have
no idea who's next could be tomorrow
morning could be a month from now but
it's coming to a theater near you and
and it and it will definitely be a very
good thing for this industry it'll be a
great thing because it'll take out all
of the bad broken business models the
heavy leverage the speculation that was
too risky and push everybody and this
kind of circles back to the conversation
you were having with ben
at wonderful
the reason i'm an investor in wonderful
is i need a place
to store my crypto assets that fit into
my compliance and accounting departments
and so
you know when wonder if i
was able to offer me
a centralized wallet it bit by i was
able to say to my auditors look
you can audit this thing daily
weekly quarterly monthly and i can mark
to market each position for you
at four o'clock even though it's
irrelevant in crypto land it trades 24
7. but the old infrastructure
of compliance that exists for all
financial markets has not yet provided
systems yet for anybody that wants to be
compliant like i have to be i don't have
an option i have to go through audit i'm
an investor in many other financial
services companies that are issuers
under regulations in many countries we
have to have our audit statements signed
then your take what's it going to take
to get to a bottom
i think these are definitely good signs
that we're getting close to the bottom
and we'll have to see how
voyager block 5 celsius play out i think
there is a potential that uh you know
some of those firms are gonna have to
liquidate large amounts of crypto which
you know will
would likely send the market uh down
further and to kevin's point
we'll you know we'll see what uh we'll
see what else comes up over the over the
coming weeks um you know i know there's
a lot of other firms that have been uh
lending and and using high risk
strategies and so it's also good as this
you know more news about these um firms
comes out because you do get more good
analysis and information about the
different strategies that they were
using and the different risk profiles um
so you know i think we'll learn a little
bit more as we go forward and sort of
see how big uh you know see how big this
uh this issue uh really really is and
you know and then obviously the other
part is the you know macro um you know
economic conditions and uh you know my
i won't throw my guesses in on that i i
feel like they're you know they're
uh
as good as anybody else's guess so
got it got it uh kevin do we have you
back i think you do
we do yeah go ahead and finish your
thought there and i it sounds to me and
maybe you can also address this the
follow-up question i had for you which
was
would you after you finish your thought
say that you're looking for a big spike
in the vix and the stock market to find
a bottom there as well
um well let's stay on crypto for a
second the point i was trying to make
when i lost audio was that
it's taken me a long time to convince my
existing compliance and accounting
infrastructure that supports my
operating companies investments across a
wide range of financial services
to get on board with my positions in
crypto because remember i i own i own
wonderfuy because i want to own
infrastructure equity same for ftx same
for circle i'm a shareholder of those
companies and immutable holdings in the
nft space that's my basket of equities
that are all compliant operations
they're all compliant they all work
under very strict compliance
that's the test that starts the equity
investment but the more interesting
challenge that i solved recently um with
wonderful again with bit by was to
actually open an account
transfer all of my projects whether it
was a polygon or
helium or whatever i mean all this stuff
to me these are not coins it's just
software that's all it is and moved it
into and slowly i'm doing this i'm not
finished yet into bit by where i can get
a statement
each month that my auditor gets before i
do and my compliance department marks to
market every day at four o'clock
and i don't you know i find it so
humorous that the whole
compliance world still marks to market
crypto at 401 pm as if that means
anything it's because it's trading 24 7.
but they mark to market it because they
have this giant infrastructure that
reports back up is there over leveraged
positions is the position more than five
percent depending on the mandate that
it's held in but
this is what wonderful is doing it's
working under the regulator under an
order completely compliant actually has
a public auditor looking at it now
signing my statements that's a big deal
that did not happen for years and that's
why i'd rather invest there because
that's going to become more and more and
more important as regulation comes the
large institutions that don't own any
crypto need the wonder flies of the
world totally compliant whether it's
decentralized or centralized and
auditors that can actually use the
infrastructure they're building to make
sure they can mark to market according
to the traditional rules of compliance
there's a commenter here asking if your
stance on nfts has changed at all from
the utility of uh nfts related to cars
or watches
i'm still a huge fan of nfts for
authentication not for trading i have
never
ever traded one until the the regulator
tells me if it's a commodity or a uh or
a security because i don't want to get
caught in that debate but i have used
them last week um there was a there was
an art exhibit on in new york and i
bought a piece and i asked the dealer
and the artist
i will not take delivery without an
authentication nft
and i and they and they said well wait a
second we don't have one i said then you
don't have a sale i want that so i can
send it to my insurance company that's
the way things are moving i'm not
trading that nft it's attached
physically if you want to think of it
that way to the piece of art i bought it
will trade when the physical art trades
but now i'm able to actually send the
nft to my insurance company and say this
is what i bought this is when i bought
it here are the attributes of it here's
its physical location it's on
transportation now down to florida to my
home and all of that is covered in this
nft so that's the future of nfts for me
you know if you i don't know about an
ape or any of that stuff because i you
know to me where's the intrinsic value
there
somebody tried to sell me an ape for 362
thousand dollars it's now worth 60.
that's not good
[Laughter]
all right last question and then i'll
open up just final comments from both of
you so this question for both of you
what happens when people like sam
bankman freed run out of money to keep
bailing out companies in the industry
and maybe we do get that mass panic
event
are retail consumers going to want to be
part of crypto when that event happens
or jump in you know after that event
happens you first kevin earlier than ben
well i have to disclose i'm a
shareholder um
ben you should be aware as a shareholder
and wonderful as well
he came in around the same time i did
i am a paid spokesperson for ftx
so i have a lot of respect for the
management there i did a lot of due
diligence before i accepted that
position because i wanted to have a
compliant home
but
sam is one of the smarter guys in this
space for this reason long before crypto
he was a traitor he understands the
power of leverage both to the dark side
and the upside of performance so i'm
going to guess and it's a personal
opinion the last guy to blow up is going
to be sam bankman freed because he
doesn't get himself caught in
over-levered positions now they've been
they're very very good in terms of
managing own business he's got a huge
team there ryan the ceo they also manage
the americas differently they do the
rest of world their compliance his
parents are compliance lawyers at
samford i mean he doesn't have a better
heritage in terms of managing this
process so i think he's probably going
to be one of the ones that picks up the
pieces and has been doing that in recent
purchases that are made public in
various platforms that are just getting
crushed it's a long-term strategic move
i think it's smart
ben your thoughts liquidity vc space
what what are you seeing uh what happens
if uh sam bakeman free runs out of money
or will he
yeah i think if if sam runs out of money
it would be interesting to see if other
more traditional financial institutions
uh step in to
participate in you know in in bailing
out some of these
some of these parties i think that'll be
interesting because we have seen a lot
of uh financial institutions make big
investments into the crypto space so i
think that'll be something to keep an
eye on uh you know government
involvement and bailouts i you know i
don't necessarily know whether that's on
the table but i think that's you know
that's the the sort of lens that i'm
looking at it through and
um
yeah it'll be interesting to see how it
plays out i do think it is great uh to
see sam and ftx stepping up and um and
you know hopefully being able to
preserve some
customer funds through the actions that
they're taking i think at the end of the
day
you know we we can look at this from an
investor standpoint from a user
standpoint you know whatever it is but
at the end of the day there are lots of
retail
users of crypto a lot of them first time
who are uh stuck out holding the bag and
with amounts of money that are very
significant to them and um and so i
think always looking at it from that
lens is really important because this is
a
an asset class and a technology that is
meant for mass adoption it's meant for
you know to be a currency of the people
and uh and and so i think we should
really never lose sight of that so i
think from that lens what sam is doing
is you know is fantastic and hopefully
he will you know will he'll be able to
you know keep keep the dollars in some
people's pockets through uh through
ftx's actions
sounds great let's get some final
thoughts from both of you maybe 60
seconds each final thoughts on the
crypto market are you waiting for that
big panic uh or uh you know what's
what's the future do we still have a
future in uh in the crypto utility
crypto investing kevin o'leary we'll
start with you uh final comments or
pitches that you want to make and then
ben and uh then uh then we will wrap it
up
i think crypto has a very bright future
i'll be bold enough to say in this very
volatile market for crypto that within a
decade it'll be the 12th sector of the s
p and the reason is there's just too
much productivity too much uh
transparency really strong vehicles for
solving financial services problems that
exist today like transferring capital as
i talked about earlier it's just too
good and too efficient and so it'll
remain
the key is we need to get some policy
we're i think it'll happen first with
stable coins and you know you asked the
question but the stock market is no
different than the crypto market the
stock market is still a little expensive
if you believe we're having a recession
probably fairly valued if we if you
think we're having a soft landing the
trouble is nobody knows so you're going
to see this fibulation going back and
forth until we've resolved that question
we know where the fed stands in further
rate hikes but there are some great
companies that have lost 20 30 40 of
their value and i have to admit i'm
nibbling in equities as well just as i
am in crypto and so i can't call the
bottom but i don't use leverage
that's the that's the secret sauce
everybody's calling me up want to lend
me money and i just say no no nanette
not interested
awesome uh
ben uh final comments from you
so definitely crypto's not dead
bitcoin's not dead i think we've
whenever we have uh
situations like this or markets like
this we've heard that question come up
time and time again over the last 10
years and i think the way to look at it
is you have these aggressive aggressive
growth cycles and then these downturns
where a lot of issues are resolved uh
previously it was with the technology um
in some cases and then
in more recent years including this year
it'll be with regulation and sort of
like really weeding out sort of you know
bad actors or people that are
are um you know not uh operating in a
way that's safe for customers and so
that's
oh it looks like my my camera is
out there but yeah so so i'll just
finish the thought so um
that is uh what we're seeing now which
is basically regulation is is going to
uh make things more stable and secure uh
for for users and investors in the space
and then uh once we get through this
cycle we'll see continued growth so i
think it's part of the natural uh growth
of the asset class and just with any
type of uh you know newer technology we
tend to see these types of uh cycles if
you like that video where did you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe